lots in the papers focusing both on the
situation in Ukraine but also in Israel
and Gaza and some really interesting
pieces around a former ambassador to
Moscow writing in The Telegraph arguing
that actually sanctions have never
worked against the Russian government
and saying that negotiation is the way
to persuade Vladimir Putin the second
piece I've written that suggests the
Russian leader would actually like to
distance himself from the separatists on
Israel and Gaza I think there's a really
good piece by David Oren ovitch in The
Times very balanced look at the
situation reflecting on David Ward the
lib dem np's tweets and also an
interesting take by Max Hastings a long
supporter of Israel saying that this
brutality is too much there's also a bit
of a domestic focus something on the
Commonwealth Games and a look at the
Prime Minister's speech yesterday where
he did praise what Europe can do for
Britain something that right wingers
might jump on and say is he really going
to get the reforms that they want